(tense tonal music)
(Jeff yelps)
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] On Tuesday,
Jeff Bezos and three other passengers
successfully completed
the first manned mission
of Blue Origin's New Shepard spacecraft.
- [Woman] Go Jeff, go
Mark, go Wally, go Oliver,
you are goin' to space.
- [Narrator] This was the
16th successful flight
for the New Shepard, but the
first with astronauts on board.
- [Man] Look at the blackness of space.
- What we're doing is the
first step of something big
and I know what that feels like,
I did it three decades ago,
almost three decades ago with Amazon,
and we are...
Big things start small.
- [Narrator] The successful flight
is yet another remarkable accomplishment
for one of the world's most
successful entrepreneurs.
The Amazon founder and former CEO
amassed one of the
world's greatest fortunes
by revolutionizing the retail
and computing businesses
and accelerating the
transition to eCommerce.
- [Photographer] Mr. Bezos,
one more here, please.
- [Narrator] Jeff Bezos
started Amazon in 1994
and served as its chief
executive for 27 years.
He built the company
from an online bookseller
into a modern colossus that
dominates American eCommerce
and is a major player in businesses
ranging from cloud computing
to digital advertising
to logistics to entertainment.
- I'm off to America!
- [Narrator] Born in
Albuquerque, New Mexico,
Bezos graduated as
valedictorian with a 4.76 GPA
from a suburban Miami high school in 1982.
Bezos attended Princeton University.
After graduation, he went into finance,
eventually joining the
hedge fund D.E. Shaw & Co.
In 1993, Bezos left his job
and decided to start an online bookstore.
He name his new company Amazon,
after the Amazon River in South America,
which seemed fitting
because it was the Earth's largest river
and he was planning to build
the world's largest bookstore.
Three years after Bezos founded
Amazon, he took it public.
The remarkable rise of
Amazon's share price
helped build Bezos' personal wealth,
which allowed him to launch
his space tourism company
Blue Origin.
Since 2000, Bezos has funded the company
by selling $1 billion worth
of Amazon stock each year.
- To see the Earth from
space, it changes you,
it changes your relationship
with this planet,
with humanity.
I wanna go on this flight
because it's a thing I've
wanted to do all my life.
- [Narrator] In mid-2000s,
Amazon expanded rapidly
with the introduction of new products,
Prime, AWS, and the Kindle.
In 2013, Bezos purchased
The Washington Post
for $250 million.
(audience cheering)
More recently, Amazon has
made big ticket acquisitions,
buying up the streaming service
Twitch, grocer Whole Foods,
and this year, Hollywood studio MGM.
(audience applauds)
Despite a long list of successes,
Amazon's rapid growth hasn't
been without its challenges.
- Amazon says it will not be building
a second headquarters in New York City.
- [Narrator] In 2018, Amazon scraped plans
for a New York City facility
after local pushback.
Last July, the CEOs of Amazon,
Apple, Facebook and Google
faced tough questions about
their business practices
during a House Antitrust Hearing.
- Mr. Bezos, are stolen
goods sold on Amazon?
- With over a million sellers,
I'm sure that it has happened,
but certainly I don't
think it's a large part
of what we're selling.
- Okay, so Mr. Bezos, basically
then you're saying yes.
- I guess so.
- [Narrator] As it has
grown in size and power,
Amazon has faced increased
criticism over everything
from the company's business tactics
to the treatment of its massive workforce
responsible for moving
goods from its warehouses
to consumers' doorsteps.
- [Reporter] After 27 years,
Jeff Bezos officially
handing the reins over
to Amazon Web Services
chief executive Andy Jassy.
- [Narrator] In July of this year,
just a few weeks before
his flight into space,
Bezos stepped down from
his CEO role at Amazon
to become an executive
chair focused on innovation.
Bezos said he plans to
focus more of his energy
on his two other properties,
The Washington Post and Blue Origin.
- We're going to build a road to space
so that our kids and their
kids can build the future.
- [Narrator] The Amazon
founder has poured billions
into his space venture
over more than two decades,
believing humanity must
ultimately establish outposts
across the solar system.
- [Jeff] Here, catch.
- Oh yeah, ping pong balls.
- [Jeff] Ready?
(man laughs)
- Here it comes.
(quirky music)
(man laughs)
- You just have to wait for it